in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Jim and
Tina are with us hey guys how are ya
welcome welcome where y'all from Duluth
Minnesota Oh fun all the way to
Nashville yep it's a bit of a haul yes
yes it and here to do your debt-free
scream yes sir how much have you paid
off sixty seven thousand six hundred and
twenty-four dollars and twenty four
cents great and how long did that take
twenty two months awesome and range of
income during that time between 80,000
and 100,000 cool what do you guys do for
a living
Tina does music for our church and I'm a
UPS driver but mostly I'm a mom
oh okay very fun cool excellent what
kind of debt was the 68000 all kinds of
dumb yeah a lot of credit cards we had
we had four chase credit cards mm-hmm
just with Chase just wow they were very
from one to another and balance
transferring all over the place we had
we had a overdraft protection credit
card on our checking account we had a
student loan we had a personal loan
couple personal loans and then our van
of course a car loan yeah of course you
were normal absolutely yes kind of
gained everything's good we're in
Minnesota life is good so what happened
what disturbed you 22 months ago
well I celebrated the 20th anniversary
of my 20th birthday and kind of looked
around and realized we didn't really
have a whole lot in savings and our
oldest daughter was getting closer to
college and we didn't have anything
there and stress was building and she
had a meltdown and I figured we probably
needed to do something about it so just
like the previous scream I too had the
mental breakdown I came I had started
listening my mom had told us years ago
yet there's this Dave Ramsey got it he
does this envelope system so I have a
photocopied sheet of Dave Ramsey's
envelope system hanging up on my
bulletin board that was kind of error
and forgotten and then I
before we got on the same page I was
kind of trying to do the envelope system
but I was only making hundred bucks a
week
and he was the big breadwinner and so I
would run out of money and then I'd go
to the cart and we would I just couldn't
do it because we weren't it wasn't to
plan together and we weren't doing it
right and then I started listening again
to the program and I came I was
listening to all the debt free screams
and he came home and locked in the door
and I'm bawling and sobbing and I said I
want to do that just like that well yeah
when you want to do something you can do
it that's how it worked that's very good
very cool
so twenty-two months ago you had that
conversation so Jim you walk in your
wife's bawling because she's listening
this crazy guy on the radio and what did
you say well at first I was skeptical
because I had heard your show a few
years before that on the local radio
station and you know you have a
perception in your mind you know about
something then redneck telling me about
finance
there you go really I need to be
listening to I I did my due diligence
awesome
looked up online to try to prove that
you know you were some kind of quick
rich scheme and yeah realize that you
know when I was reading these websites
of people telling me how bad you were
they were probably sitting in a basement
somewhere in your mom's house and mm-hmm
you know so I started listening to the
show and after about two or three days
of you yelling at me for everything I've
done wrong I decided well it's probably
it's probably time to do that he really
did come home he said well I've been
listening to Dave yell at me all day so
your wife's crying Dave's yelling at you
you got no chance you're in a corner
you're painted in a corner here yeah
you're dead love it so then at that
point you sit down to do budgets or what
what happened well actually the last
thing I put on the Amazon credit card
was your book
Oh last spring I probably shouldn't say
that but it was true too late you did
yeah I did so but and then we we went
through the class and that was that
changed everything
and then so you went to Financial Peace
University yes sir at your church or we
started teaching the class at our church
we talked about our church lady thank
you so that's that's the end of the
story then well the next chapter in that
door okay cool very cool
Lisa now you're just like all in with
this redneck I missed that part and mind
you he's the city slicker I'm the
country bumpkin so he's kind of calling
me a redneck - okay this is great I love
it absolutely fun so how does it feel
now that you're free fabulous it's a
beautiful thing it's undescribable
indescribable it's so freeing I've had a
smile on my face for how long now so I
love it couple weeks just everything is
so different
we took this trip down here we've been
able to come and we're spending a whole
week mm-hmm we have cash in our wallets
and there's no stress there's no stress
we after well we didn't talk about week
nine week nine we started to dread week
nine of the class because we court so
when we went through was that we were
driving home from the last class and the
car overheated so we had to get that
thing we had to get a ride home and that
was several hundred dollars but it was
the best thing in the world because even
at that point we'd only been doing it
for how long have we been doing this
little honor than that because we kind
of started before we took the class with
me and we counted out $1,100 on to the
cash on earth
able to pay for a car repair that would
have just totally put us over the edge
before I mean we would we would freak
out and go okay it's 150 how are we
gonna do that and now it was like oh
seven heard that's not so bad
it feels really amazing to be able to do
that and so then when we coordinated the
class right around that week nine points
we had more car issues with his car and
nursery time yeah there was like three
different times and we sat you that's it
we're just gonna skip week nine you
should make an eight week course yeah
Financial Peace University is hard on
cars where it messes up cars for people
all the time cuz it's like God is saying
this is a test I want to see if you're
really gonna do this so now that you're
coordinating a class and someone says
you paid off sixty eight thousand how
did you do that what do you tell them
the secrets are well I think the budget
is key but for me it was wise listening
to your show and and you've just gotten
done with a debt free scream and and you
said okay so now what are you gonna do
yeah you yeah I'm talking to you he says
you got yourself into this mess
you can get yourself out and that's when
it hit me that I have a choice in this
matter that you know I used to be under
the impression that you know you're
controlled by mm-hm you know outside
variables and your your your finances
controlled what you did with your money
but once I came to that realization and
had that paradigm that whole paradigm
shift that I had control that's
everything it was huge
that's a that's a breakthrough that you
know that that puts you in control of a
lot of things it really does it really
does you guys are amazing I'm honored to
talk to you and you brought the kiddos
with you what ages one of their ages and
names
Ali is fifteen Abby is 13 for 13 yes
still 13 I don't know how old my kids
are I know I have three of them and
Gwendolyn is for awesomeness okay and
we're gonna give you a copy of Chris
Hogan signed book for the next stage
next chapter
of your life all right Jim and Tina
Allison Abigail and Gwendolyn Duluth
Minnesota $68,000 paid off in 22 months
count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three two
one what a great family absolutely
awesome well done you guys very very
proud of you this is the Dave Ramsey
show hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or twenty seven
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
common